ça c'est accueil ma tendresse ou le ski
bonsoir monsieur zulawski alors tout le
monde connaît angeles qui évidemment
l'important c'est d'aimer possession la
femme publique l'amour brac mes nuits
sont plus belles que vos jours chamanga
la fidélité vous êtes également
essayiste et écrivain et vous publiez
votre 20e libre ça je sais pas si les
gens ne savent votre 20e bouquin je le
savais toi toi qui évidemment chez stock
auparavant à la 20e en polonais
attendait parce que quelqu'un ment
française pas tous dans le quatrième
livre en france et 20e livre en pologne
l'infidélité publié par agnès par r
jeanne éditrice française qui était allé
vous convaincre en pologne de faire
traduire ce livre le réparer s'est
réfugié dans une dans une forêt près de
varsovie que vous l'idée retranché comme
ça dans un chalet il me rend 600 m² 909
sans erreur
ira et qu'est ce vous faites buvait de
la vodka vous taper à la machine toute
la journée mais je vois dans votre
carnet je suis polonais un chapelet
nazis non ça fait trois ans que je suis
un tout petit peu en dehors des choses
il le fallait j'ai eu quelques
bouleversements difficile dans la vie
donc c'est pas la peine de parler et
donc je me suis retrouvé dans une maison
que j'avais acheté avant et qui est une
maison d'antan dans un énorme parc
national qui donne sur une forêt donc on
construira jamais rien en face de moi il
ya des loups il ya des serres et à
l'état d'imo y avait eu des sangliers
c'est ce que voulait et je suis très
heureux là dedans ouais mais c'était un
peu une grande solitude et jean mercier
1 et ce par air ou alors le livre était
surtout du graphite
on peut le dire c'est pas non non non
c'est un auto roman comme on dit au
roman d'adam autrement il ya auto hier à
berne
vers la fin c'est l'histoire d'un
philosophe qui soupçonne sa femme
actrice de le tromper frederik je les
lui oui j'ai lu pas ce que je fait que
les étrangers pour voici une page dans
les six noms
dans deux semaines sur le livre est très
franchement je ne suis pas un fanatique
du cinéma très hystérique de zulawski
mais j'ai beaucoup mais c'est ce qui
n'est pas injurieux c'est un cinéma
paroxystique de seine s'est tendue vers
les acteurs bon mais ça n'a rien à voir
ce livre là est au contraire extrêmement
doux extrêmement calme même si à la fin
il ya un crescendo violent c'est un
livre de rencontre et il ya donc
effectivement une double narration mais
s'il ya deux philosophes dont l'un a été
quittée quand même par une actrice un
les deux qui gère les lieux samedi à
daniel daniel hains qui ressemble un
petit peu pardon une histoire vraie mais
c'est un c'est un livre alors là
franchement il ya des choses assez et de
la description de pubis féminins tout à
fait l'excitante et précise
et puis des dialogues qui moi me fait
penser à philippe rohff donc c'est un je
pense que c'est un écrivain
effectivement soulas qu'ils ccc il ya
beaucoup d'humour beaucoup de fils il ya
quand même bien andreu mans une héroïne
qui est actrice qui s'appelle daniel qui
tourne loin d'eux qu'ils dont il
soupçonne qu'elle le trompe bien sûr
d'où le changement de titre qui est un
clin d'oeil à mon avis par rapport à la
fidélité exactement c'est ça merci une
fabrique oui oui c'est le c'est
l'éternel problème
est-ce que nous sommes assez intéressant
dans nos biographie dans ma vie sauf la
vôtre madame pour nous mettre devant
dire voilà regardez moi je suis
absolument sublime et il faut m'écoute
et me lire je vais vous raconter mon
truc je ne pense pas tout à fait ça je
pense que que la différence entre la
l'autobiographie et le roman est quand
même très nette
et quand je dis autrement c'est que il
faut relancer l'auto quoi il faut il
faut en faire des choses dans cet ac 1
pour moi j'ai vu votre autobiographie je
suis désolé c'est à dire que elle tourne
loin de lui lui la soupçonne de le
tromper les gens qui l'entourent vous
appelez ça les gens de mer de la cour de
l'actrice en question vous appelez ça
les gens de mer va moi c'est à hollywood
on appelle ça le chef pippo est la
traduction exacte
un genre de merde oui donc gênant est ce
que vous êtes en train de s'expliquer
l'accès à un roman qui n'est pas
autobiographique ans que j'essaie de
vous dire que ça ne te roman c'est à
dire que l'appartement est aussi
importante que la par auto alors ceux
qui s'amusent véritablement à suivre le
voici et le gala et le machin là ils
verront sans doute
loto mais ceux qui aiment la littérature
et les romans d'accord voilà verront le
mettez dans la catégorie et lecteurs de
voici l'album coup on peut dire qu'il
avoue en avoir
je sais pas moi je vois cette actrice
qui tourne
loin d'une ancienne fiancée sophie
marceau qui qui qui tourne loin lui bois
alors effectivement cette boisson créé
des perturbations dans sa vie érotique
elle par hollywood
il l'a rejoint rêve en anglais alors moi
je suis très content effectivement en
tant que lecteur de gestion vous êtes 4
et quand vous n'êtes pas crédible
non si elle a fait john kerry vrai
vraiment très loin d'être con alors
ouais donnez moi la grâce d'être moins
con d'accord façon ça va j'ai
l'impression que c'est un livre sur la
douleur c'est un livre sur sur un un
homme seul mais il n'est pas
spécialement fidèles lui non plus le
narrateur il s'ennuie pas de son côté
ses tresses et très sexuel enfin james
bond il y en a eu trois françaises de
daniel qui ont fait des james bond mais
on peut choisir laquelle s si on veut
vraiment j'avais pas nous expliquer
quand même que c'est pas de ce qui
marche ou non qui saisit quand même non
je veux vous expliquer que ma vie privée
me regarde moi même pour vous faites des
bouquins sur votre vie privée alors à
ces patients avaient privé informant
ouais
thierry non en fait sauf il a tiré la
première radio n'a fait son film parlez
moi d'amour je sais pas je n'ai pas vu
vous l'avez pas vu monsieur je vous lis
à cette histoire d'un intello renfermait
coléreux un peu alcoolique monacale
comment savez-vous sa part parce que
vous savez quel est le titre de son
roman le premier qu'elle a écrit
d'ailleurs le seul mais là c'est une
menteuse
ça vous dit quelque chose c'est bien
il a elle préparera porteuse mais
beaucoup de travail de six jeux qui vous
ne sais pas je voudrais pas que ça
descende là parce que je pense que que
ces gels eu la velléité de penser que
c'est un vrai bouquin ouais et les vrais
bouquins sont fait de notre trip notre
souffrance de ce conseil mais ils ne
sont pas là pour faire des dénonciations
des d'espèces d'appel personnel je ne
voudrais pas conçu comme ça je serais
très mal hausse comme ça je crois que
c'est une conversation très intéressante
parce que très littéraire arabe on
appelle ça le mentir vrai c'est
exactement ça il ya pas la seule donc
c'est un c'était intéressant vous ayez
cette conversation
une certaine manière si le lecteur et
voyeur c'est son problème ce n'est pas
le nôtre
mais il a tous les droits oui est ce
qu'elle est tellement informé par le les
journaux le public la télévision il a il
a tous les droits
et en plus on se dira pas ça moi je ne
me dérobe pas
thierry je me dérobe pas à dire qu' une
partie du bouquin parle d'une vérité que
je connais ouais mais je ne dis pas que
c'est l'entière vérité et je ne dis pas
intégralement que c'est le portrait
craché de quelqu'un ou de quelque chose
c'est parce que j'ai aimé dans le
bouquin justement c'est ce que j'aurai
ce que j'aurai vécu à votre place c'est
à dire cette sensation de non non non je
vous en prie vous entraînez n'est pas ce
que j'ai vécu
alors moi je leur en vendre il n'allait
pas qu'ils en vivent alors que la zambie
mois voilà sur ses terres et donc quand
le héros sais pas vous mais on vérifie
le calcul en se disant est ce qu elle a
eu le temps de voir l'autre c'est grave
quand vous parlez de rudolf woodtli qui
enferme sa femme de 26 ans à clé et
hellmand il est jaloux non je veux pas
vivre ça j'avais raison
vous avez raison c'est quand un film je
sais pas je sais pas pendant trois ans à
l'idée
quand j'entendais le mohcine films
cinéma acteur actrice je venais quand
même un peu vert pâle donc j'avais pas
très envie c'était pas petit sens c'est
une expérience de la vie maintenant ça
s'écarte et puis je pense que les phares
sont revenus pour encore une fois
embêter beaucoup de monde avec un film
un peu trop ceci ou un peu trop cela
voilà ça revient je n'ai vu qu'un film
de vous c'est l'important c'est d'aimer
trouvé ça super c'est pas franchement à
grand film merci merci en tous les cas
d'avoir été assez
en prime
e